Today,
we're going to talk a little bit about,
I guess you could call them the
underlying structures of perception.
I picked this image.
It's a very old image.
It's,
it's an,
it's an image that that portrays.
Man,
I'm being cast up on the beach by whale.
It's Jonah Biblical figure and in this
is the story of Jonah.
Jonah was owed on a rough ocean storm
and he had been commanded by God to do
something which he was ignoring and uh,
the storm was sufficiently rough so that
he got cast overboard.
It was eaten by this giant.
This is a whale as far as the medieval
medieval people were concerned.
It's obviously not what we would think
of as a whale,
but they didn't know much about whales
anyways.
He was swallowed up by a whale and then
cast back up on shore a number of days
later.
It's a death and rebirth story.
And the reason I use it as an image is
because
it represents something of psychological
import that you're all familiar with,
but that you might not know that you're
familiar with.
Symbols are often like that.
Assemble often stands for something that
you know,
but that you don't know that you know,
there's lots of things that you know
that you don't know that you know,
almost everything is like that.
In fact.
And it's rather obvious if you think
about it because if you are transparent
to yourself and you knew everything,
you knew,
you wouldn't have to study anything
about psychology because you'd
understand that yourself completely.
And we understand ourselves poorly.
And so we have to study ourselves as
individuals and then,
you know,
as,
as phenomena in the world as,
as other people and that edit and
there's mammals in this animals and as
living things and as political actors
and so on,
just to get some minor notion of what's
actually going on.
And what that means in part is that
you're more complicated than you can
understand.
And when you hear,
say psychoanalytic thinkers talking
about ideas like the unconscious,
the unconscious is actually a
representation in some ways of the fact
that there's far more to you than you
know about.
And that what that means also is that
there are different kinds of
unconscious.
And we certainly know that to be the
case.
There are different kinds of memory,
for example.
So a lot of your procedural knowledge is
unconscious.
And so your procedural knowledge is what
allows you to do things like ride a bike
or walk for that matter,
because you don't really know how you
walk.
You haven't,
it's actually a controlled fall.
So you lean forward and then you use
your legs to stop you from falling on
the ground.
It's,
it's,
it's encoded in your architecture rather
than something and it's apprehensible to
your conscious understanding.
Now there are lots of,
there are lots of phenomena that are
procedural in the unconscious.
And then there was sort of borderline
phenomena that you have some idea about
that you can represent,
but you still don't completely
understand.
So what sorts of representations tend to
be more into just stick?
And those are the sorts of things maybe
that pop up in your fantasies and your
dreams.
And those are also this sorts of
unconscious sources of knowledge that
allow you to understand,
say,
complex work works of literature or art
that draw their meaning from multiple
sources,
simultaneous seely and attempt to inform
you on a deep level about how things are
connected and how they're different.
Now this particular image is a journey
to the underworld image,
and that's a very,
very old idea.
Journey to the underworld.
It's maybe the oldest myth.
It's one of the oldest mythological
ideas or one of the oldest archetipal
ideas.
And the underworld is,
it's a difficult,
it's a difficult phenomenon to grasp,
although you can certainly encountered
the concept,
particularly in movies.
So for most of you know,
how many of you have seen all the Harry
Potter movies,
right?
So,
right,
of course.
And so in the second movie,
I believe it's the second movie where
pottery counters of basilisk underneath
hogwarts,
is that right?
The second one?
Yeah.
Well,
that story is a journey to the
underworld story and the architectural
setup of the kind of the of the movie.
By architectural setup.
I mean the relationship of Hogwarts,
the castle to the underground structures
is a symbolic representation of the
representation of consciousness embedded
in culture.
And so that would be partnered as
friends and bedded in the realm of
magical knowledge,
so to speak.
It's outside of them.
And that's,
that's represented by the castle,
you know,
uh,
it's a representation of knowledge cast
in stone.
So that's a form of memory to cast
something in stone.
And so potter and his friends are being
enculturated in this enclosed
environment in the safe enclosed
environments like a university,
like the university,
more on the other side of the campus
then on this side for,
for various reasons.
Now underneath the,
the well in the background,
of course,
in the Potter series,
there's a battle between good and evil
going on.
And that's also an extremely old
architectural idea.
And that's an idea that's probably as
old as human beings.
And that's partly because human beings
are very strange creatures and they're
capable of very,
uh,
what would you call profound acts of
deception.
And one of the things that separates
human beings from most other animals is
our capacity to use deception and it's
associated with our imaginativeness,
right?
Because we can imagine a variety of
alternative potential realities and move
towards them.
That opens the door for us to deceive
ourselves and others because we can
replace our accurate vision of the world
in so far as it's accurate with whatever
vision and representation we wish to
choose.
One of the things you find in childhood
development,
for example,
is that the smarter child,
the earlier they learn to lie and it's
an offshoot of the ability to use
fantasy,
and so the idea of good versus evil part
comes out of that to some degree because
if you're dealing with people,
you're always dealing with phenomena
that can trick you in some way.
They can represent reality as other than
it is,
and that that's a tremendous problem for
human beings because it makes other
people extremely difficult to figure
out.
Now,
if you're honest and straight forward,
then you're easy to figure out because
you don't have to be figured out.
I can just take you at your word,
which means you'll tell me something and
it'll be relatively straight forward.
I'll be able to understand it and then
you'll go do it.
No problem.
I don't have to know anything about you.
On the other hand,
if you don't do things according to what
you say you'll do,
then Europe,
bottomless pit of incomprehensibility
and God only knows what you're going to
be up to.
And so that,
that's an architectural problem for
human beings.
And that's the problem of having to deal
with the late deceptive capacity of
other people.
And of course the for ourselves.
So that's all going on in the background
and the Potter series.
But underneath the castle,
for example,
there is,
remember what's under the castle in the
second,
in the second film,
what is it?
It's a,
it's a vassilis,
right?
Yeah.
And what happens when you look at a
LISC,
right?
And so what,
what might that mean if you're thinking
about it intelligently,
say w what?
What phenomena might that,
that represent?
What happens to prey animals when they
encounter of creditor,
they freeze.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So it's a representation of the fact
that there are certain classes of
phenomena that will freeze you on site
and you freeze because there are parts
of your brain that respond to phenomena
in the external world as if you are
praying.
And the reason for that is,
well per first you are,
and second from an evolutionary
perspective,
you're your ancestry going back say tens
of millions of years is an ancestry that
was composed of predessessors that we're
continually preyed upon.
And we have entire systems in our brain
that react to the class of potentially
predatory events.
Now for human beings,
that system has differentiated
cognitively so that many of the things
that we would experience as predatory
threats in the modern world don't come
in the shape of say crocodiles and and
bears and you know,
giant cats and so forth.
The sorts of things that would
necessarily pray on you in the night.
But there are analogous in that
the outcome is the same.
You can be preyed upon by many things
you can be preyed upon by,
you know,
a corrupt corporation.
And so it's perfectly reasonable to
symbolize the actions of a corrupt
corporation as a form of predation.
And also to categorize that even more
deeply as a reflection of the underlying
consequences of the fact that people can
deceive each other.
Those sorts of get deep very,
very rapidly.
But there they're active and living
representations in the,
they still represent something that's
profoundly true,
which is not so much what things are in
enough of themselves,
which is what science does,
but what things are in relationship to
you,
which is more like what things mean and
things generally have a motivational or
emotional meaning.
And that meaning is generally quite
tightly tied to the necessity that you
have to survive and to thrive and to,
you know,
to find someone to be with and to
reproduce in all the Darwinian things
that you're supposed to be up to.
So a lot of these more archaic
categories,
are there meaningful categories,
their categories of meeting that's,
that's an,
that's a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at it,
knowing the partner situation,
which is related to this image.
The one that's up here.
The idea is that everything that's
stable
rests on something that's unstable and
dangerous.
And that's underneath in the potter
series.
And then the other thing that happens
continually in the series,
but particularly in the second episode,
particularly in the second episode,
is that partner has to go down the neat
things to encounter something that's
terrifying and deadly.
That's,
that's actually preying on his friends
and on the community.
So it's a,
it's very much like,
for example,
the hobbit having to go off and,
and,
uh,
steel treasure from,
from smog.
I think the dragon's name is,
and except that in the,
in the potter sequence,
the Dragon,
which is the basilisk,
they're equivalent.
It's the same thing as this,
um,
in the,
in the hall,
but the Dragon Court's goal.
Whereas in the potter representation,
what does the basilisk guard,
what's it,
what has it captured?
It's the little redheaded girl,
right,
Jimmy?
Right.
And that's a very,
that's a very old story.
Now,
no partners kind of in love with her
right now.
I mean,
they're young and sort of platonic,
but you know,
you can see the relationship sort of
burgeoning.
And now he has to confront this thing
that's terrifying,
that exists underneath everything in
order to free this original finger from
the clutches of something terrible in
Reptilian.
Now that's a very,
very interesting story.
That and what it means,
a whole variety of things.
And what it means to some degree is
that,
uh,
a male human being can't really become
mature until he confronts the terrible
things that lie underneath the civilized
veneer of society.
That's one thing that means,
uh,
another thing it means is that
it's the capacity.
It's the capacity of the male in that
situation to do that,
that makes him attractive enough to wake
up to females that he might be
associated with.
So that's like a sleeping beauty motif.
Um,
it has evolutionary echoes because much
of what we've battled with for the last
60 million years say,
because I think you can trace the
development of our cognitive structures
quite straightforwardly,
back 60 billion years,
there's been an endless battle between
human beings and predators,
and many of those predators were
reptilian.
And so,
you know,
we're the result of a very,
very long battle between mammals and
reptiles.
And in our case particularly,
it appears that part of the reason we
evolved our tool using the past to get
aren't great capacity for vision was
because our ancestors were continually
preyed upon by predatory snakes when
they lived in trees.
And that's a long time ago.
And so he's,
he's symbolic representations are
unbelievably archaic and they're kind of
as archaic as the underlying biological
systems in your brain that,
that provide you with motivation and
emotion.
And those are extremely old.
You share those with while you share
those with any animal that you have any
hope whatsoever of understanding at all.
And that even means lizards.
You know,
my daughter had these lizards that were
called,
I can't remember,
unfortunately,
there in the desert kind of lizard and
they make a good initial pet,
but they're,
they're very funny little creatures
cause they,
you know,
they're very lizard light being that
they're lizards and they have points a
little bit.
And if you put them in water,
they puff themselves up,
which is quite fun.
And then they zoom around in the water.
But more importantly,
they like to stack on top of each other.
They're very,
very social and they're friendly,
which is not exactly something that
you'd expect from a lizard.
But,
but my,
my point is that even something that's
distant as that from you and the
evolutionary hierarchy shares enough
commonality of biological structure with
you so that you can understand a fair
bit of it's motivation.
So for sample it's pretty easy to tell
when one of those lizards,
even though they're basically friendly,
it's angry cause it'll puff up his and
you know right away you don't have to
have a discussion with the rest of your
family to figure out that that's an
angry lizard.
Right.
And see it maps onto your body
immediately.
And you know,
the same thing applies to snakes even
applies to insects.
Lots of insects have developed the kind
of warning behavior that will
immediately signal to you that you're
about to be bitten or it's usually been
with insects.
So,
so this is all to say that there are
levels of understanding that are
underneath say your,
your,
your normative,
mundane,
day to day comprehension that informed
everything that you do with deep levels
of meaning.
And a lot of the activities that you
pursue that you might regard as
entertaining,
actually draw on those representations
and you find them entertaining because
they're actually deeply meaningful.
Now the idea that a man can be swallowed
or human being because there are myths
like [inaudible] where the protagonist
is clearly female,
where they the,
there's an underground journey and then
a reemergence.
And,
and that's the journey to the
underworld.
That's the journey that Terry partner
undertakes continually,
by the way,
throughout the far series,
the underworld,
taking different forms,
um,
as the,
as the series progressed,
um,
now that's also with death and rebirth
idea.
And,
and that's,
that's a very old and profound idea and
I think it's actually one of the most
profound ideas that human beings have.
And it's the idea that
you will spend time in your life
underground.
Now you might think,
well,
what does that mean?
Well,
it means what the potter movie,
the second part of movie,
it was trying to represent it,
which is that there will be times in
your mind where you are faced with
things that will terrify you into
paralysis.
And that will take you underneath your
normal set of assumptions.
Because when your normal set of
assumptions are functioning,
you don't end up facing something that's
terrifying enough to,
to freeze you.
When your normal set of assumptions that
are working,
the world stays happily predictable
around you.
And most of the time that's where you
are.
And that's the normal world that's blown
apart.
Whenever something that you're
attempting to do fails in a dramatic or
less dramatic way,
the more dramatic the way,
the deeper you go into the underworld
and the underworld is in some sense the
substructures of your preset positions.
Now you,
you know this already because I don't
suppose there's a single person in
realize and spent some time in the
underworld,
so to speak,
because this is what happens when
something terrible happens to you.
Unpredictable,
a terrible.
And you know,
there's sort of classic categories of
events that send you to the underworld,
you know,
um,
the death of someone you love,
a serious illness of some sort,
either for you or for someone you love.
Um,
the death of a dream of some sort,
you know,
so you've got some goals that you think
is really important and all of a sudden
you find out for one reason or another
that there's just no way you're going to
be able to pursue it.
A betrayal that's a really good one.
People,
that's a really rough one.
And that'll send you for,
that'll throw you for a loop for sure.
So they're all,
they're all elements of the part of the
world that you can't control.
That in some sense always remains beyond
your control.
That has in some sense a predatory
relationship too,
because it could devour you at least
metaphysically.
And when that happens,
you go somewhere and the place that you
go is very dangerous.
It's underneath everything.
And maybe you come back out and if you
come back out,
what that means is that you've
reconstructed your erroneous
presupposition so that you can function
once again in the world.
And,
but maybe you don't.
Maybe you don't.
So people who have post traumatic stress
disorder,
for example,
they go into the underworld and just
stay there.
And you know,
and if you're,
if you're chronically depressed or if he
can't get over your grief,
or if you're in a state of continual
anxiety and upset or if you're
nihilistic for that matter,
you exist essentially in an underworld
domain because you can't master the
perceptual apparatus that culturally
informed perceptual apparatus that would
help you orient yourself in the world so
that the things that you want to have
happen and that you need to have happen
actually happened.
So that's what that picture means.
It also means,
at least in principle,
that you know people have the capacity
to die and be reborn at different levels
of analysis.
So you know,
there are minor disappointments that you
encounter when you have to drop some
precept position that you have and let
it die and then put a new one in its
place and that's painful,
but it's nowhere near as painful.
It's holding onto the things when they
don't work because then you just end up
wandering around just sort of clouded
collection of dad presuppositions and
nothing that you ever want will happen
under that circumstance because you're,
you're,
you're armed with tools that don't fit
the world and you know,
when you tried to apply them,
the world won't do what you want them to
do and then that's endlessly anxiety
provoking and frustrating.
So part of
pain is as part of the price that you
paid in some ways for being updatable
no,
because the world transforms around you
and as a consequence you have to be able
to transform with it.
Otherwise it runs ahead of you and you
get left behind that,
you know,
that happens to people to some degree.
Anyway,
it says the age,
that's actually one of the evolutionary
explanations for why people got,
cause it's a mystery right there.
There were elements of you,
they're rewarding.
You don't want to just sounds that
give,
rise to you.
What are immortal there?
You know,
the DNA that produced,
he was at least three and a half billion
years old.
It might be older than that.
So structures getting entertained
themselves over unbelievably vast
expanses of time.
So it's not self evident why human
beings have to die like we do and we die
at about after you're done being a
grandparent is kind of when you're,
when you're done.
And the hypothesis is is that at that
point,
in some sense it's too costly to keep
you updated and you have to be replaced
by a younger version of twitter.
Of course,
eat your grandchildren or whatever.
You know,
when you've sort of exhausted your
plasticity and flexibility,
the job that it's cheaper just to
replace you then to update.
So
that's kind of a drag.
But yeah.
Nope.
All right.
So here's the funny question for you.
This is the question that scientists are
always devoted towards answering.
What's the world made up?
Well,
that's a complicated question.
I mean,
the simple answer is that it's made out
of matter
and that matter is made out of this.
And that theory was the room originally
formulated by Democritus Kabaka.
This didn't exactly say that the world
was made up us.
You said the world was of atoms.
And space and that actually happens to
matter because the way that atoms are
arranged in space gives rise to another
property which has information.
And so if you haven't Adams in space,
you also have information and you can
think of the world is being made of
information just as easily as you can
think of it as being made of matter.
In fact,
I think that,
and you know I'm not alone in this cycle
emphasis that it's actually more useful
to conceive of the ground of reality as
being something like information rather
than being something like matter.
But we don't have to discuss that at
lake at the moment.
What we'll say instead is that one,
one way of looking at the world is the
materialistic perspective and the
materialistic perspective is a very
powerful perspective and it's basically
the dominant for about since the time of
gale Galileo,
that's,
that's about when that prospective got
thoroughly going.
And for many reasons,
bacon,
descartes as well were major players in
the establishment of the materialistic
framework.
And it came about because in many ways,
because people were suffering from their
inability to understand objective
reality.
So,
you know,
we still suffer from that because there
are all sorts of diseases we don't know
what to do with and we age and you know,
things don't work out exactly like
they're supposed to.
And so we pay a big price for our
ignorance.
And so we're motivated to overcome it.
And one way we have overcome it was by
developing materialistic philosophy and
not materialistic philosophy enabled us
to specify the structure of certain
elements of the world and then to learn
to predict and control it at least to
some degree.
Now you know,
you learn to predict and control
something and sometimes you generate
more monsters doing that.
So that's problematic.
But all things considered,
I think it's a lot better to live now
that until live three or 400 years ago.
So or maybe even 30 years ago for that
matter.
So it looks like the whole materialistic
thing is be doing a lot of good for us.
But there it also has some serious
problems and the problems have to do
with another fundamental problem that
human beings have to solve,
which is what you should do about what
is.
And because human beings are dynamic and
active creatures.
And so we do not only,
we're not mere machines of
representation,
we don't just care what the world is.
We care what you should do with the
world.
And the reason we care for that,
well,
the fundamental reason if you're
thinking about it from a scientific
perspective,
is essentially Darwinian.
And I think that you can,
you can imagine the conflict between the
moral worldview and the materialistic
worldview as a battle in some sense
between Newton and Darwin.
So Newton was the,
was the author,
the fundamental author of the idea that
the world was made out of material and
men and operated like a machine,
you know,
which was a pretty powerful perspective.
That perspective came about during the
time of clocks.
And when Europeans in particular,
we're starting to build things that
would function in a very predictable
manner once they were set in motion.
So Newton in some sense was influenced
by that at an assumed that the entire
cosmos could be understood as a
deterministic machine.
Um,
and the,
that it would be ultimately predictable
and controllable.
And in a famous statement,
and I don't think this was new,
and although I can't remember,
it might've been descartes
anyways.
The idea is that if you knew the
position of every subatomic or Vr,
every odd atomic particle in existence,
if you knew the position and the
momentum of those particles,
that you could then predict the entire
outcome of the future.
It was strictly deterministic.
And the only thing that stopped you from
being able to describe everything in
terms of machinery was your ignorance.
It was,
there was nothing at the bottom of the
cosmos,
so to speak,
that was fundamentally unknowable.
Well,
that turned out to be wrong.
It wasn't really discovered to be wrong
until,
you know,
the first couple of decades of the 20th
century.
But it definitely turned out to be
wrong.
We now know that in under no conceivable
conditions could we gather enough
information to predict the outcome of
what appears to be a relatively
unpredictable costco's.
There are levels of resolution that
remained relatively constant and that
you can manipulate.
But our hope for total knowledgist is
gone.
And that was mostly your consequence of
the development of quantum mechanics.
And the quantum theories have never
failed an experimental tests.
They're the most powerful theories that
human beings have ever designed.
So in some ways they seem,
well they're probably not final,
but they're,
they're pretty final,
so,
okay.
Nope.
Okay,
so,
so that's sort of the materialist stand
if things now,
now there's a Darwinian and the face.
And the reason I'm telling you about
both of these things is because part of
what we need to solve in order to
progress properly with this course,
we need to solve the problem of exactly
what constitutes truth.
Now,
the first thing that I might say is that
truth in some ways,
whether or not something is true is a
question that's sort of like whether or
not a tool that you have does the job
that it has.
It's not so much a question about the
ultimate nature of reality because you
can't get a truth that completely
informs you about the ultimate teacher
in reality.
So you're sort of stuck with partial
truths.
And so then you might ask,
well,
how do you tell a useful partial truth
from a non useful partial truth or maybe
a partial truth from a lie or from
fiction?
It's a very complicated to do that,
but one way you can progress towards
that is to start thinking about things
in terms of their tool like
capability.
And that's a pragmatic approach.
By the way,
from Intel esophageal perspective,
the pragmatists who were very influenced
by Charles dark,
by the way,
came to the conclusion at the beginning
of the 20th century.
That truth was bounded by claims of
practicality.
So if you're trying to determine whether
a statement is true,
the implicit question that goes along
with that is true in relationship to
what end.
So,
and the question then is sort of like,
is your tool that you're using to
represent the world or to act on it good
enough to do what you're trying to do
with it?
And then if it's good enough,
then you're playing just true enough.
Now this is tightly tied to Darwinian
philosophy and the pragmatists recognize
this right away.
The private just for American group,
as philosophers who worked on the east
coast,
particularly in Boston,
and they were,
they immediately took Darwinian
Darwinian hypothesis to their,
to their,
to their heart,
so to speak.
Because the Darwinian hypothesis is also
pragmatic.
That Darwinian hypothesis says whatever
reality is,
is and also becomes.
So it's something,
but it's something that's changing too.
And it changes in a way that's actually
not predictable.
It's technically,
it's not predictable.
It's like the stock market in that way.
There are periods of time over which you
can make predictions,
but if you wait long enough,
no matter what you think you're going to
end up wrong.
Especially given what knowledge is for a
human being because your knowledge is
bounded that you know.
And so the way the Darwinian process
souls,
that is by death essentially things that
aren't good enough to solve the problem
that currently presents the presents
itself to them either die or failed to
reproduce and to the degree that
organisms can come up with truth claims
that are sufficient than they live long
enough to reproduce and then the next
generation faces the same problem and
that's always the way it is is that
truth chases a reality that's
fundamentally unpredictable and it's
transforming constantly.
Now,
the reason,
the reason I want to tell you that he
said the important thing to understand
because I'm going to make a claim here,
is that the ways of looking at the world
that are more mythological than material
are also real ways of looking at the
world.
And it's not what people generally think
because you think about fiction,
it's not real.
Underneath fiction isn't mythology and
religious claims and that sort of thing.
That's the domain of fiction in
pathology and we don't think about that
as real,
but that's because we think about what's
real from a Newtonian perspective and
not from a Darwinian perspective,
from a Darwinian perspective,
this is also a claim that nature may,
you said truth serves the life.
Like what Darwin would say is you can't
define truth in any other way than that
which serves life.
That's it.
You're not going to get past that.
There isn't a truth past that.
The truth as far as a bounded living
organism is concerned and that certainly
needs us,
is the body of knowledge,
conceptual and embodied that best
enables survival in the face of
continual transformation.
And that's that.
There's nothing under it.
Now,
as soon as you know that,
then what happens is that it turns out
that the things that mean things to you
are also real.
Now,
science is a funny business,
right?
Because what science attempted to do and
for good and for
very useful reasons was to strip
everything subjective and subjectively
meaningful off the picture of the world,
right?
So if you're a scientist,
you want to be objective.
And part of the way you do that is by
turning to suppress your own
subjectivity in the search for the
objective truth.
But also you do that by relying on other
people's observations.
So we kind of make a deal.
And the deal is if I see it and can
describe it and you see it and can
describe it,
and then a bunch of other people do the
same thing and we come to the same
conclusion,
we're going to treat that as real.
And that's useful.
It's useful because it,
it's useful to specify things precisely
and to put them in the appropriate
categories.
And in a sense,
that's what science does,
is that it continually strives to
differentiate,
differentiate things and put them in
identifiable categories.
And that means that increasingly we're
able to use what we categorize as
knowledge to help us confront the world.
So,
you know,
it's a,
it's a great,
it's a great process,
brilliant process.
And it's even more remarkable because
relatively stupid people could do it
because it's a,
it's algorithmic based,
you know,
the science is a method.
And so once you know the method,
you don't even have to be that smart to
make progress.
You could just grind away at something
with the method and sooner or later
you'll produce new information.
And,
and that's,
that's,
that's a great thing.
You know,
it's like a science is like a factory
that produces knowledge so well,
so that's wonderful.
But
what's not so wonderful about it
arguably is that it's,
in some sense,
war are our concept of what constitutes
reality.
And it's never really solved as far as I
can tell,
this conflict between the Newtonian
perspective on what's real at a
Darwinian perspective,
on what's real.
And as far as I can tell Darren and
trump's new,
and that's true if you're a biologist
for sure,
because there isn't anything that's more
true that sits underneath biology,
didn't a theory of natural selection.
And that's partly a philosophical claim.
And the claim is because you can't
represent all of the external reality
with ultimate accuracy.
You're going to fail in everything
that's bounded or even everything that's
not as complex as the thing that's
trying to be represented is going to
fail.
So how do you deal with,
how do you deal with that?
You generate variations and it somewhat
has to be somewhat random because you
don't know what's coming.
You generate random variations and then
hopefully one of those variations will
work in relationship to whatever is
coming.
And so it's also a kind of truth,
20 minutes and embodied truth claim,
right?
You carry the fundamental truth of your
existence in the shape of your
physiology.
So in on earlier claims a philosophical
truth where most of the disembodied,
you know,
there was some implicit idea that the
consciousness or the soul was more real
than the block.
Well,
it's nice to think about that in some
ways because it opens the door to the
idea of things like in mortality,
but it doesn't seem to be very
okay.
It's hard not to associate that with a
drink.
All right.
So category systems
w
when you encounter something that
frightens you,
your body categorizes it and it
categorizes it as something that
presents a danger or threat to you.
And danger is the probability that
something will damage you.
Like it'll be too loud or too hot or too
cold,
it'll damage your sensory systems or
directly pose a threat to your
physiological or psychological
integrity.
And so your design,
so to speak,
to protect yourself against that,
you feel pain for that reason.
And instead of paying,
you also feel anxiety,
which alerts you to the fact that you
might feel pain and should do something
about that you should freeze or you
should run away.
And so for example,
what,
what that,
what emerges from that is the beginnings
of a natural category system.
So you could say,
well,
here's one useful category.
That is the category of all things that
you should freeze at or run away from.
And that's a deep category.
It's a biologically predicated category.
And it's also a category that has
meaning,
right?
Because the meaning is what you should
do when something like that shows up.
It's not,
the meaning isn't stripped out of the
category at all.
It's actually fundamental.
Now it turns out that a lot of our
perceptions,
when people think about the way they
perceived the world,
they think well out there a bunch of
objects and you look at them and once
you look at them,
you see them and once you see them,
you figure out what they are and then
you evaluate what you should do and you
progress on that basis.
Right?
It's so object perception,
cognition,
emotion,
action.
While the problem with that is it's
wrong.
And the first reason it's wrong is
because things don't exist out in the
world as self.
Evidently separable entities hardly
because everything can be segregated
into smaller entities and every entity
can be aggregated together with larger
entities.
And so the boundary that defines
something as a self evident,
the entity is not by no means clear.
So part of the way that your body deals
with that is by categorizing things with
regards to their immediate impact for
you.
And so when you look at something,
so let's say you're looking at this and
you say,
well that's a bottle.
And so you might ask,
well what is your brain doing when
you're looking at that?
And the answer is it's molding your body
to prepare to pick that thing up.
And that's how it understands it.
So your eyes,
I received a pattern that's constant
across some duration.
It's not made of smoke,
it's made of something that lasts.
So there's a pattern here,
a bottle pattern that lasts across time.
You have some sense of what it is having
interacted with these sorts of things
before,
but also its shape obviously indicates
that it's a grippable thing.
And so what that means is that when you
look at it,
your eyes activate your motor cortex
directly,
even before you see the object,
like before you form an image of it and
your imagination,
your retina,
the pattern when you rent.
And that activates your grit,
right handed or left handed,
whichever hand you happened to be.
And part of what you're seeing when you
see that bottle is what you would do
with it if you were interacting with it.
So you see the manner in which you would
interact with us.
And that's the case for virtually
everything that you see.
So for example,
when you look at a chair,
your body prepares to sit in the chair
and maybe to stand on the chair if
you're going to change a light pole or
we know when you look at your computer,
you see the keyboard because that's the
thing.
You move your fingers up and down on.
And so your perception is tightly tied
to the implication of objects for action
immediately.
Now you might say,
well that's not real.
That's not the reality of it.
The reality of it is the objective
thing.
But as I said already,
it depends on how you define reality.
You take a Newtonian Newtonian tap on it
or our Darwinian attack and from the
Darwinian perspective,
the implication of something for
auctions actually its primary meaning,
which is don't stand around and
contemplate a tiger.
Well,
it's trying to eat you because the fact
that it's trying to eat you is more
important than the fact that it's a
tiger.
And if you don't figure that out quick,
then you're not around anymore.
And so much for your claims to truth,
that's just,
you're just gone.
That's an error,
right?
And whatever was in you that enabled you
to make that error is not going to be
transmitted to the next generation,
or at least hopefully not.
So there's a domain of categorization
that has to do with the meaning of
things.
Now,
most of what the psychologists have
dealt with who are clinical
psychologists,
does actually the domain of
categorization that has to do with the
meaning of things.
And it's actually because as far as
you're concerned in your life as a,
as a human being,
you live inside a network of meanings of
things,
right?
So for example,
when you look at your mother,
you're not looking at her at her as an
object and then attributing all sorts of
meanings to her.
You see the meaning of your mother right
away.
And that meaning is multidimensional.
It has a very long history and it
affects you directly on a physiological
and maybe you hate her and so the sight
of your mother makes your heart race and
your and your brain produce cortisol
because she's categorized as
unpredictable and chronic threat.
That's a standard story in situation.
No one would laugh if there wasn't
sometimes that was true.
Those are Friday and slips.
By the way,
when you discuss something like that and
people laugh,
then that's an admission on their part,
like an deeply unconscious admission on
their part that there is truth to this
statement and it's also a truth that is
somewhat painful to admit.
So you can tell that.
You can tell that when you're listening
to Comedians,
they do that all the time,
right?
They tell you something that's
absolutely brutally evident that no one
will admit.
And everyone laughs and that is a
Freudian slip technically,
because Freud often listened to the
sorts of things that would make his
patients laugh or make an audience that
he was speaking too loud because that
would give him some insights into what
they were repressing,
so to speak,
and what they would allow to come to
light.
So when jokes are often about things
that are taboo,
right?
It's hard to make a joke about something
that isn't taboo.
So,
all right,
so I've kind of made it a classification
structure of these two different ways of
looking at things.
There's the meaning centered way of
looking at things and the meaning is
then the implication of the thing for
action on your part.
And it's a more materialistic centered
thing,
which is sort of like the world as it
exists if you weren't here,
right?
That's a,
that's this fundamental hypothesis of
sciences that we're,
there's something around that would be
here and look the way it does.
Look now,
if none of you were around,
you know,
it's possible that that's true.
And it's also possible that it's,
it's possible.
It's possible that it's not true,
but most possible is the fact that it's
true in a way that we really don't
understand because the existence of
things,
the way we perceive them as clearly
dependent on our existence as a
perceiver.
And so what the nature of the world
would be if there was no one around at
all perceive it.
If there was no such thing as
consciousnesses effect,
that is a completely unsolved problem.
So maybe it would be like a field of
quantum potential or something like
that.
But,
but it isn't even possible to really
understand what that means.
So
now having established that,
having established,
I'll give you another example before we
move on.
So I said,
for example,
that when you interact with objects
around you,
you're not really interacting with
objects.
It's more like you're interacting with
tools because you're a primary concern
is,
well,
what the,
what's the world in relationship to me?
What do I have to avoid?
You know,
if I'm going to get to where I'm going
and what can I use to further my
pursuits?
And so you're like that deeply.
That's why human beings are tool using
creatures,
right?
We have hands and they manipulate the
world and those hands are there.
They're built into our cognitive
architecture.
Like it's not like our brain is separate
from our hands,
far,
it's,
it's very opposite to that.
We wouldn't have the brains we have if
we didn't have the hands we have.
That's why things like is by the way,
or Octopi are very intelligent.
They are,
even though they're invertebrates,
they only live a couple of years,
so they can't learn that much.
But they're extraordinarily intelligent
and it's partly because they're tactical
within the,
because they are technical,
they can grab things and manipulate them
and so you know,
they've developed an intelligence that's
identifiable to us because we have
little tentacles on the ends of our
hands and you know,
we're using them to fiddling around with
the world at the time.
So
now
there's the perceptual
reality,
which is that we know about already,
that when you look at something and we
track the way that you're interacting
with,
we know that one of the first things
that happen happens is the relationship
between the perceived object and your
body is established very rapidly.
Okay.
Because you want to map the object onto
your body so you know what the hell to
do.
Orient yourself so that you're safe and
productive.
At the same time,
there's a guy named
Jj Gibson Gibson who was uh,
uh,
psychology psychologist.
The perception you operated in the late
seventies people thought his theories
were
they weren't behavioral,
that's for sure.
They were going to have a different
classification or category.
And Gibson also made the first sort of
claim that what you saw in the world
where things like tools,
he called them affordances.
And so for example,
when you approach what you would call
from an objective perspective,
a cliff,
Gibson would say,
you don't see a cliff.
You see a falling off place and you
might need from cliff.
But you see falling off place.
And if you think about it,
again from a Darwinian perspective,
of course you see falling off place.
That's why you know you,
you might shrink from a precipice is
your whole being perceives that as a
place that would instantly make you
extinct.
It's not a secondary derivation from
your analysis of a set of objective
facts.
It's that primary perception.
And it has to be because you better move
quick.
If you're to New York cliff,
you don't have any time to think.
The same thing occurs when maybe you're
being,
you know,
potentially struck by a snake.
You have circuits in your brain that
will see that snake and make you jump
way before you know it's a snake.
Because sick around standing around
waiting for the image of snake to
forming your consciousness means that
you'd be bitten five to six times
already because you're just going fast
enough to see and then move you see move
and then proceed.
And that's what keeps you safe.
And so a lot of,
a lot of what you've perceived in the
world or the meetings that you've mapped
onto your body.
So,
so then you can think what human beings
have done in response to this bifurcated
way of perceiving reality is we've
developed two different systems of
classification to deal with it.
Now for most of human history,
we only had one,
and the one we had was basically that
meaningful system.
It wasn't the scientific system,
right?
We didn't get around to figuring that
out.
Even the ancient Greeks and the Romans,
the Greeks in particular who were
unbelievably intelligent,
really never gotten around to pause.
Something like that.
Objective reality.
And if certainly the Romans didn't,
there was no science.
Science only evolved in Europe and only
you know,
the late 1500 it's very strange and it's
very difficult to understand.
So we'd been elaborating out this
materialistic viewpoint for only about
500 years.
It's not very long.
The other viewpoint,
that's the natural habitat of humanity
and that's the viewpoint that's made up
of all the stories that people have told
about themselves in the world since the
dawn of human consciousness.
And that's really,
those are the knowledge forms,
the stories that actually constitute the
base of culture.
Because culture is not so much about
what the world is and how to perceive it
as it is about how you should act in
relationship to the world.
And so when you read fiction and when
you talk to each other endlessly about
what your friends are up to and what
their friends are up to and what they're
doing on facebook.
And when you go to movies and you watch
actors act out roles and you know when
you do everything you do to examine
other people around you,
that you're betting yourself in this
ancient culture that's there to tell you
how you should operate yourself in the
world,
what you should do,
because that's a primary question.
You need to know what to do.
Human beings need to know what to do
because if you don't know what to do,
well that's a very unpleasant emotional
state.
And that's partly because it indicates
that you're not willing adapt it to your
current circumstances.
You know,
if you just stand around long enough not
knowing what to do,
you'll age and you'll die.
It's not an effective way of dealing
with the world.
You have to be oriented towards
something and the,
the job with culture in part is to tell
you to what you should be oriented and
that's where the rubber hits the road
with regards to psychology because
especially in its clinical variants and
personality theory has to be an element
of clinical clip.
Personality theory has to be a sub
element of clinical theory.
What psychology has to contend with,
as I mentioned in the first lecture,
is not only what you are but what you
should be and the reason for that is
you,
when you're talking about a human being,
you can't separate out the bare facts
that present you about the person from
the ideal.
We do this all the time.
What's mental health?
Well,
you could say,
well,
it's the absence of mental illness.
You know,
really if someone tells you that you
should just stop the conversation
because all they'd done is
solve one problem with an equally large
problem.
There's no progress there.
It's,
it's a kind of a smart Alec he thing to
do.
You know,
it sort of means going into a lot of
the,
with your stupid question,
mental health,
if you want to understand what mental
health is,
it's because it's very difficult to get,
people did find it.
You have to watch how they act when
they're talking about such things as
mental health because then you can
derive some sense of what they actually
understand about it,
our presume about it instead of what
they just say about,
right.
So if you look at how society's use the
idea of mental health,
they partly do use it normatively and if
it's used normatively,
then describing it as the absence of
mental illness actually works.
Say well you're healthy to the degree
that you're normal.
And so extremes outside of normality
start to border on pathology.
But there's obvious limitations and
problems with that approach,
right?
Because we don't think the average
person is the best looking person.
And we'd assume that attractiveness is,
it's an ideal towards which we might all
at least aspire.
And it turns out there's deep biological
reasons for that because most of the
things that men and women find
attractive about each other are they
find you attractive for deep biological
reasons,
like symmetry for example,
which is an indication of sort of
optimal biological development,
um,
for men,
for women looking at men that's shoulder
to waist ratio and for what men looking
at women,
it's w waist to hip ratio,
which should be about 0.68,
which is pretty damned precise.
And you know,
men are always computing that when
they're,
when they're looking around.
So,
so,
um,
you can't talk about what constitutes
health by merely making a normative
claim.
You also have to take into account
something like deviation from an ideal.
And that's a weird thing because of
course the ideal doesn't really exist
that that's what makes it ideal.
But you can't get away from that problem
if you're going to do anything serious
about psychology.
Because implicit in the idea,
not only of mental health but of health
itself is the,
is the question what constitutes an
ideal human being?
And he might think,
well,
that's not so relevant.
You know,
why would that be relevant to pursue?
And I would say as well as people were
not only ever engaged to this scientific
pursuit,
right?
We're engaged in the business of living
and we might be scientists sort of as a
subset of that,
but,
and then I would also say that if we're
dealing in the realm of health and
mental health were not being scientists
anyways,
we're being,
it's like philosophical engineers
because what we're doing is we're
attempting to take our knowledge,
however it's being gathered,
including scientifically and to make
things better,
not worse.
And when you're trying to make things
better,
you're not being a scientist.
What a scientist is trying to do is to
describe what things are as soon as
that's transformed into like
engineering,
say it's more,
it's,
it is still,
it becomes a variation of applied.
It's like applied philosophy.
It's a different domain.
And I think it's not right to just skip
over that and pretend that what we're
studying,
say an a personality class is something
we can only be studied scientifically
because it's not,
maybe you can study people's conceptions
of what constitutes ideal
scientifically,
but you're still faced with the problem
with that.
The question of what is the ideal
lingers underneath all the phenomena
that you're trying to understand and
explain.
So beauty,
that's a good example.
Intelligence,
we tend to assume that more is better,
right?
We don't think the average is the right
place to stop.
And in fact,
that's,
you know,
all of you people,
there's not a single person in here,
I suspect,
who has an average Iq.
You're probably minimally at the 85th
percentile and most of you are at the
95th percentile.
So that's also,
remember I told you last summit,
last class that scientists are like,
you know,
albino elephants.
They're very rare.
And you guys are like that too.
You're not normal human beings.
So it's true.
You know,
and as you progress up the ladder of
success,
you'll be in increasing contact with
stranger and stranger variance of
humanity because the successful people
who are smart and highly conscientious
say are smart and highly creative,
are a tiny minority of the human
population.
And that's unfortunate.
Seriously unfortunate.
But,
um,
you're the beneficiaries of the lottery
that determined in part here genetic,
the genetic structure of your
intelligence.
So I suspect I've done some testing of u
of t students and the average comes out
at around 126 to 130 that's two standard
deviations above the mean.
So,
and you know,
it's probably actually higher than that
because a lot of you have English as a
second language and so that tends to
suppress your,
your,
you know,
your performance on Iq tests if they're
assessing verbal knowledge.
Anyway,
so,
all right,
let's
see.
So part of what I'm going to talk to you
today about is the sorts of things that
Carl Young would called archetypes.
And archetype is a ill defined term.
And that's,
that's partly why it's very difficult to
understand you.
It's also very difficult to transform
the sorts of things that he had to say
into very precise scientific
formulations,
but
okay.
But that doesn't change the fact that
it's extraordinarily useful from the
perspective of general understanding.
It's just useful thing to pursue.
And also from the perspective of
practical utility to understand
something about these archetypical
categories.
And the reason for that is you're in
their grit.
Now,
one of the things that you can set,
this is a brilliant thing.
It's terrifying and psychoanalysts are
terrifying people.
Freud's Beth not,
you know,
because Freud dug around in this
pathology of the family and families can
be great,
but if you want real pathology of
families,
a good place to look.
So because of pathological family is so
pathological that it's unbelievable.
And that's actually what Freud was
interested in.
And it's,
it's,
again,
it's hard for normal sort of healthy
people to appreciate that because if
you're normal and healthy and your
family's kind of,
you know,
not half bad,
you don't have all those Freud,
he had problems.
But if you do have them,
that's all you have.
You never get out.
You're trapped in there like that,
like a fly in a spider's Web that the
flying spiders with common symbol
representation of the classic Freudian
situation.
So,
um,
okay.
So I'm going to show you this picture
because I want to talk to you about a
category system that will be useful in
understanding what we're going to go
through during this course.
So what I would like to do with all of
you is to start from the bottom of
things.
And that's what we were doing today when
we were talking about definitions of
truth.
So I asked you to consider for a moment
that there's two ways of looking at
truth.
One is your objective sort of Newtonian
way,
which by the way is outdated.
We still hold it because it's
practically useful.
And the other is the Darwinian
perspective,
which is the world is meaningful in
relationship to you and those meetings
are real and so forth.
And so far as they have a bearing on
whether or not you actually survive.
So,
and then you make the claim that there
isn't anything more real fan,
whether or not you survive,
you can't get under that.
That's where you start.
So,
so you could say,
I could say for example,
if the pursuit of the Newtonian theory
of reality culminated in the extinction
of human beings saying because our
technological power got so great,
that would be perfect evidence for its
lack of truth because there are things
that just wasn't taking into account.
Right?
Because something that's true should
take things into account.
And one of the things that you take into
account is that we're living things that
we can only exist under a certain,
you know,
within certain parameters and that were
also oriented towards an ideal.
And if your theory doesn't take that
into account,
well maybe not only is it into plate,
it might be pathologically and,
and,
and genocidally.
All right,
this is a representation from ancient
Egypt.
Um,
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
what the representations mean.
So this first one here is horace and
this person here is a service.
And that person there is isis and Osiris
is the god of tradition.
And that's why he sorta standing there
on that pillar.
And so the Egyptians thought of these
three,
there's one other,
there's seth and seth is a bad guy.
So Seth is the evil villain that's
always whispering in the king's ear.
You see that story repeated in all sorts
of different forms.
So seth is,
it's a negative figure and he's not
included in these particular image,
but we'll,
we'll get to him.
Seth is also,
by the way,
oh cirruses brethren.
So,
and that's because the Egyptians had
figured out,
and this is like 3000 years be seen,
the Egyptians had already figured out
and if you put a state together,
so the state would be represented by
ocirus and ocirus is sort of like the
abstraction of the patriarchal force
that stands behind the tradition.
So if you imagine that a tradition has a
way of behaving,
if that's what it tradition is to the
degree that you share a tradition,
you're all manifesting the same pattern.
And the Egyptians would say that pattern
that you're imitating,
that's a day.
That's,
I mean they,
they didn't think of it that way because
they didn't think the way we think.
But for all intensive purposes,
the phenomena that they described as a
god was the pattern that everyone was
unconsciously re imitating.
Now you have to unconsciously imitate
the same pattern or you can't get along,
right?
So in,
in,
in our society for example,
we have a body of laws and most of it's
derived from English common law and
English common law emerge as a
consequence of the
necessity to solve disputes between
people.
So that all hell didn't break loose.
So English common law was produced when
one person took another person to court
to say,
we've got a serious problem.
We don't know how to organize our
behavior in the same space.
You have to make a ruling.
So then the judge would assess the
situation and state who had the right to
do what.
And then that became part of the law.
Now in so far as you are law abiding
citizens,
and so you abide by the body of law,
you actually manifest the body of law
and your behavior.
And to the degree that you do that,
other people like you to agree that you
don't do that.
You're either poorly trained,
poorly socialized,
antisocial,
or,
or downright dangerous,
in which case other people,
we'll put you somewhere where you're
have less harm than you might be.
So like it or not,
you're a mimicker.
And what you mimic is the central
pattern of cultural behavior that has
evolved over who knows how long,
forever,
forever.
And so far as some of its associated say
with dominance,
hierarchy,
behavior,
which is unbelievably old.
That's so serious,
not so serious.
That's God the father,
so to speak.
And it's part of,
it's part of the category of culture.
Now the Egyptians also knew that culture
was not only necessarily a good thing as
a,
of course all of you know because no
doubt sometimes you note that you're the
beneficiary of your culture,
but sometimes no doubt.
You also feel you're like crushed and
mistreated and mold.
And pantone was shaped by the culture
because the culture says you better act
like everybody else expects you to.
And of course that's necessary,
but you're not exactly like everybody
else.
So you couldn't get mangled and crunched
and you know,
male formed as you're socialized,
even though you also learn to speak and
you learn to read and you learn all
those things that culture can provide
with,
you know,
the Egyptians knew even 3000 years ago
that although culture was necessary,
it was an element of existence that
human beings were always in bed.
Now that's why it's a permanent
category.
There's no non cultural people.
You can't be a human being without a
culture.
It's,
it's not possible.
We're,
we're evolving.
Our,
our physiological form presumes that
we're going to emerge into the world in
a culture and that will inform us as we
develop.
That's why we have such a long
developmental period,
right?
We are,
we're born unformed.
And the only reason that works is
because
the lack of formed has been consistently
manifested in an environment that would
form it.
So culture isn't just culture.
It's the environment that we had habit,
because culture has been around for so
long.
And I'll give you one example of that.
So a big part of every culture is Darwin
attire,
right?
And a dominance hierarchy says who has
what access to what at what given time.
It pretty much every creature is in the
dominant charge.
Chickens earning dominance hierarchies.
That's the pecking order,
right?
Members of wolves packs are in
dominance.
Archi span.
Member of members of chimpanzee troops
are in governance.
Hardy's songbirds are in dominance tire.
You know,
here's what Satan in this frame,
it's all pretty,
it's not little little birds sitting out
there saying,
I'm healthy and loud and if you come
over here,
I'll check into debt because this is my
tree.
And so
and so the songbirds distribute
themselves around the neighborhood by
dominance.
And the more dominant birds get vendor
nastic spaces and better means they
don't get rained on,
or at least not as much.
They did their nest don't get blown out
of trees.
There's not so many cats around and
they're close to a good food source.
And so that makes them attractive to
potential meaning partners.
But it also increases the probability
that their chicks will survive.
And so,
and here's,
here's the nasty bit of truth that goes
along with that.
So let's say there's a bunch of birds in
the neighborhood and some kind of bird
flu.
It's specific to birds kind of wafting
through and it's killing murders.
Well,
the birds died from the bottom of the
dormant attire.
Chiappe and the reason for that is the
bottom birds are all stressed out
because their life is hard.
And when they're stressed,
they're immune system gets suppressed
and you know,
they're all frazzled from,
you know,
being chased by cats and so on.
And then they die.
And so the talkers,
and the same thing happens in human
populations.
When I'm playing sweeps through,
people die from the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy up.
And so dominance hierarchies mattered.
And so birds have them in lizards have
them.
And fish have the,
so in a school of fish,
the dominant fish,
when the fish bowl up,
they do that to make it hard for
predators to eat them.
The big dominant Fisher in the middle of
that ball,
the little sucker,
useless Fisher on the outside.
And that's what gets eaten up when the
predators come along.
So,
and we know the dominance hierarchy
stretch back a very long time.
So we know for example,
that lobsters live in Darwin and sorry
he's,
I told you a little bit about that and
there are about 300 million years old.
So what that means is that we've been
existing in siding cultural structure
because the culture is predicated on a
dominance hierarchy,
right?
That's the patriarchy.
If you want to use,
you know,
a politically correct term that's been
around for 300 million years.
So to think about it as a permanent
constituent element of reality is
extremely useful because again,
here,
here's another question for you.
Even if you don't buy the sort of
meaning argument with regards to
categorization,
there's another way you can look at it.
You might say to yourself,
what's most real?
That's,
that's a tough one because you know,
we,
we kind of accept gradations of real
like rock seemed pretty real.
Trees seem pretty real.
Um,
the environment is that real?
That's a harder one,
right?
Cause it's an abstraction about numbers.
Are they real?
You can certainly do real things with
them.
Once you,
once you get numbers,
especially zero,
which seems not to exist at all,
as soon as you get zero,
there's all sorts of magical things you
can do.
So anyways,
my point is,
it's not all that obvious to figure out
what constitutes real.
But here's,
here's a hitch.
The longer something has been around,
the more real it is.
Okay,
dominance hierarchies have been around
longer than trees.
They're really,
they're really,
really real.
And you live in one.
And not only do you live in one,
you're really motivated to get to the
top of that well in order to create one
that you can be at the top of it.
Because human beings are sneaky thing.
Because if we're not doing so well in
the dominance hierarchy,
we might think,
well,
hell,
with this dominance hierarchy,
we'll just make a new one.
And that's what creativity is.
So if you're really creative,
you can make your own dog and it's
hurricane,
you can sit right at the top of it.
And so that's how it's worked out very
well for human beings.
You know?
And in fact,
one of the fundamental traits of human
beings is openness and openness is
actually a trade that basically assesses
the degree to which you're capable of
playing around with the rules.
So you could come up with your own
dominance heart,
and that's what you do if you're
creative because you make a new set of
rules.
That's what a creative person does.
It's very sneaky.
So it's very important to be near the
top of the dominance hierarchy because
it means you live.
That's good.
You live without so much stress.
That's also good.
And your probability of successfully
reproducing or say of having many mating
opportunities goes off,
especially in the case of men,
it's,
it's like an ed.
It's like an exponential improvement.
So if you ever wonder why men are so
competitive,
that's the reason it's because the loser
men get nothing.
Really.
That's exactly how it works.
And the winter man,
they get everything and there's actually
a law that goes behind that and economic
law,
you can look it up.
It's called the pareto distribution.
You look up the prieto distribution.
It's the law that describes the income
inequality.
They don't tell you something important
about how the world works and Prieto
distribution,
which is almost everyone gets nothing
and almost no one gets everything.
That's a frito distribution.
It covers the production of everything
that's created money.
Inventions are like music,
paintings,
you name it.
If people creatively produce it,
hardly anyone does all of it and almost
everyone does none of it.
So it's a really winner take all
situation,
his heart,
he you set up.
And really as a reflection of that fact,
we also know for example,
just to hammer the point home is that if
you make dominance hierarchy steep like
a steep one is hard to climb.
And there's a lot of difference between
top and bottom,
the steeper the dominance hierarchy in
any given geographical locale,
the higher the murder rate among men
cause they start to kill each other.
And the reason they started to kill each
other's because that's a good way of
attaining dominance if you haven't gone
any other routes.
And so that's the relationship between
income inequality and the
destabilization of society.
That's an extraordinarily powerful
relationship.
So,
for example,
you can describe the steepness of a
dominance hierarchy using a statistic
called the Gini Coefficient and the
correlation between the Gini Coefficient
and the male homicide rates in North
America is about 0.8 0.8 is like,
okay,
you're done.
You don't have to figure anything else
out.
You know why it happens.
It just covers.
You never see it.
You never see an explanation that
complete in psychology.
It's like the most powerful effect ever
discovered.
So dominance artists,
this person,
he's painted the Darwin,
it's Harvey.
So you could think about him as the
person who created it.
That's one way of looking at it and you
can sort of think of him as the
embodiment of it.
So,
and he's a symbol.
That's another way of looking at it
because this,
this,
this king,
because he's a k annual serious,
he's also a god.
It was also the Egyptian Pharaoh because
the Egyptians presumed that they're
feral was ocirus and he had to take on
the being of those serious when he
became cake,
when it was coronated.
It's like when you're not a person
anymore,
you're the embodiment of the state.
And that happens to people when they're,
when they turned into the president of
the United States,
for example,
they're not whoever they were,
they're hardly them at all.
They're now is this.
And that's the thing that's at the top
of the dominant term.
And it's the thing that represents
culture.
Now the Egyptians knew that it could go
stray to become tyrannical in religion.
And that's why Oh,
serious had an evil brothers sad.
But we won't talk about him for a
moment.
Now he's the upper world.
This is isis.
Isis is his wife,
and Isis is queen of the underworld.
And she's,
the reason she's feminine as far as,
as far as we can tell,
is because from a symbolic perspective,
femininity represents more of like
possibility rather than actuality.
And the reason for that is that the
defining characteristic of the feminine
is the capacity to bring forth new
forms.
And so if you're gonna use the feminine
as a symbolic representation,
you're going to use it to represent the
domain from which new forms come emerge,
the domain from which new forms emerge
and that sort of the domain of the
unknown or the domain of nature,
which is why it's mother nature and Isis
is mother nature,
but she's also queen of the underworld
and she had,
isis had an immense following in the
ancient world and variance of Isis.
They like her as a,
as a goddess of worship.
Her,
her span of existence was thousands and
thousands of years.
I mean,
even a lot of the attention that's paid
towards married Catholicism is a
variation of the generation that was
shown the isis,
that stuff often on top of her head
there.
That's usually a very intense with
president,
Moon warhol.
I think in this particular situation,
that's actually,
those are actually accountable.
Okay,
so cirrus and Isis and they are teams,
so their wedding together order and
chaos,
they're wedded together and ordered.
That's culture and chaos.
That's nature.
Those are the two most fundamental
constituent elements of the world from
the mythological or symbolic
perspective.
And what that means is there's always
been cultured,
at least always discoursed.
Any of us need to bother with it.
There's always been an interpretive
framework through which conscious
creatures viewed the world.
You can,
you can't be without having a structure.
And that structure is inculcated inside
you in a lot of it's culturally
transmitted,
don't all of a lot of it.
So it's,
it's a precondition for existence that
you're a structured thing and that
structure is ordered.
And then the other element of existence
is that there are things that are
outside of that order.
All ways that you can't cope with
because you're a finite thing and your
culture is a finite and founded thing.
And outside of that,
there's mystery and there's mystery.
Like an outside is a funny place because
it's not outside in the,
in the way that you think about being
outside of building.
Although it is that in so far as it's
cold and dangerous out there.
But there's outsides everywhere.
So,
for example,
if you're,
if you know someone,
maybe you're in a relationship with them
and you know you're kinda comfortable
with them and then one day you're having
a conversation with them and they tell
you something shocking.
Like maybe you're,
you're in an intimate relationship with
them and they tell you that maybe it's
the day they tell you that they are
having an affair or maybe that they had
five that they're still going on.
Who knows?
And then all of a sudden one second you
were inside a close and isolated and
comfortable cultural space.
And the next second you're outside.
And that's because no matter where you
are,
the boundaries of your known Joanie
extends so far and the fact that you're
very limited in what you apprehend can
be made manifest to you at any moment.
Any of your presuppositions can fail,
especially in relationship to other
people or yourself.
You know,
because if you're all of a sudden
informed by a longterm partner that they
have been having an affair,
like that certainly says something about
them.
But it's certainly also says something
about you.
It's like how dumb can you get,
right?
How did you not notice?
How are you so naive and you might think
it's cruel to blame the victim and no
doubt it is,
but it's irrelevant in this case because
that's what you're going to think in any
case,
right?
You know,
cause you're wandering around thinking
you're a reasonably perceptive and well
adapted creature and all of a sudden
poof,
someone pulls the rug out from
underneath you.
It's like you might doubt them and
certainly you will and maybe
relationships for a long time,
but you could also be sure you're going
to doubt yourself and your past,
which is weird because you think it was
already done with and your presence and
your future's like all of a sudden,
Bang,
you're not in culture anymore.
Poof,
you're in the underworld
order.
Chaos now ordered chaos,
masculine,
feminine.
That's Yin and Yang as well.
They can unite to produce some third
thing and that's often the sun.
It can be the sun as in the thing that
shines,
but also in terms of the biological son,
there are complicated reasons that those
two things are interrelated.
This is horace and he's the offspring,
the child of Isis and Osiris.
And I won't tell you the entire story,
but I'll,
I'll tell you a couple of things about
chorus that are worth knowing.
You've all seen the Egyptian I right
the,
with the way the eyebrow,
everyone's seen that.
It's kind of weird cause it's really old
but you all know it.
Hey that's for us.
And if you look at the Egyptian Idi was
really open.
So that's an element of what horse is.
Horace is in fact open eye.
So horace you could think of as the god
of attention.
It's not to go out of intellect is a
very,
is a very important difference.
It's horace is the god of attention.
And that's also why is this
representation.
You see he's got the head of a bird.
It's not any old brewery.
It's a fault.
And the reason the Egyptians put the
head of a Falcon on choruses because
falcons can really see,
they're like super observant.
So they fly above everything so they can
see everywhere there,
above everything there,
even above the dominance hierarchies
there way up there in the sky.
And from that position in the sky,
they can see everything and that makes
them powerful.
And so the Egyptian on the was that the
proper downloads between order and chaos
made you alert with your eyes open.
And that was what made you,
that's that.
That was an element of human divinity,
so to speak.
That was,
that was the deepest expression of your
soul.
Here's the way of thinking about that.
So what happens to you if you're
somewhere where everything is entirely
predictable and comfortable?
What do you do?
You get lazy.
You get bored.
What else happens?
Well,
you certainly,
you don't have to pay attention,
right?
So what happens when you released,
stopped paying attention?
You Fall Asleep,
right?
Because you know you're fighting the
fire.
We just have a nice meal.
You know that like nothing's going to
come rampaging through your front door.
And so what the hell do you have to be
awake for?
Oof Asleep?
So now that's good.
You know,
sometimes you don't have to sleep,
but as a lifestyle,
it's somewhat limiting.
So if you're just sitting around hyper
comfortable all the time,
it's like you get all Doley and useless
and it's not helpful.
That's the sort of couch potato thing,
right?
It's not helpful because if anything
does come along,
you're in trouble.
And plus you're nothing like you could
be.
And so you might think,
well the more ordered the better,
but which is exactly what fascists think
by the way.
But the problem with too much order is
that there's no utility and you even
being there cause everything's perfect
and it's already done.
You might as well just be asleep.
There's no need for consciousness.
So you want to have a little chaos
around.
And then you might ask,
well how much chaos?
And that answer would be,
well how about not enough to paralyze
you because that's too much.
Then you're just praying and you might
be awake.
But it's like
it's
terror is a form of consciousness I
suppose.
But we might as well not presume that
it's the optimal form.
It's also rather self limiting because
if you're terrified long enough,
you'll just die.
So it's not an optimal state.
It's also one you'll strive generally to
avoid.
So let's say,
well,
how much chaos should you have around
how much of what's unpredictable should
you have around?
And we could say just enough to make you
optimally awake,
right?
So you should be pushing yourself hard
enough at each point.
You want to be,
have one foot in order.
Yes.
So you're secure and stable and you have
one foot in chaos so that you're not
exactly sure what's going to happen
next.
So that you're pushed to transform and
change and grow and develop.
And you can tell when you're there
because then you're alert and you're
paying attention.
And so at that point,
the Egyptians would say,
well then you're optimally embodied
horace,
who's the third element of experience?
One ordered to pay off,
three,
the thing that mediates between order of
males.
And if you're doing that optimally,
then you know the end of the Yang
symbol.
I think I've got it here,
actually.
Maybe.
Yes.
Those are two circuits,
by the way,
for black surface that's paid on us.
And it's an interesting symbol because
there's a white circle in the middle of
it,
right?
And that means that things might be
pretty gloomy and dark because it's all
chaotic.
But at any point order can arise out of
that.
And you know how that is.
You know when you go through a terrible
period of transformation and
everything's instead get shaky and like
it passes him.
Maybe you're even better off than you
were before and maybe not.
But at least sometimes it happens.
And then the white circle and had the
black guy.
And that's because,
well,
you know,
just when you think you're safe,
the rug gets pulled out from underneath
you.
So there's a dynamic,
this is what the Dallas believe and what
they state explicitly.
The world is a dynamic between chaos and
order.
The world of experience,
the world that human beings existed.
It's a dynamic between chaos and order
and the function of a human being is to
juggle those and keep the ballots.
And you can tell when you're doing now
because you're awake and you were paying
attention.
And not only are you healthy in who and
what you are,
but you're moving towards something
better.
And when that happens to you,
then you're possessed by a deep
intimation of meaning because meaning
signifies something.
And what it signifies is that you're in
the right place at the right time.
And so you can learn to stay there by
paying attention to the balance of chaos
and order in your life.
And the better you get at staying there,
this is the kickoff for from the
Egyptian perspective.
The better you get at staying there,
the more in permian impermeable you are
to chaos and order because you can learn
to handle it.
So you might say,
well,
life presents you with a challenge with
regards to its ultimate significance,
right?
You might say,
well,
what's the use of human striving in the
face of everything that's terrible in
the world,
including our own vulnerability as well?
You're not going to eliminate that,
but it's possible that if you balance
things properly that you can learn to
live with it.
And maybe you can even learn to
understand that those two,
the dynamism between those two things,
it's actually a precondition for va and
that without it,
there wouldn't be any big because part
of you is limited to part of you isn't.
If that wasn't the case,
there wouldn't be you.
So the question arises,
it's an existential question.
What do you do with that set of facts?
And it looks like your nervous system,
in a sense,
has already set up to answer that.
Pay Attention.
Put yourself in a situation where you're
paying attention.
If you pay enough attention,
you're right in the place that you
should be,
that will be at least sufficient.
And maybe it be more than that.
Maybe you'll say it's okay.
Terrible preconditions of existence are
justified by the manner in which it
manifests itself.
And that's a definition of mental
health.
And that's implicit in all the clinical
theories that we're going to investigate
trump the duration of the course.
Okay.